[Music]
character's hair's a little out of
control in the past that you've
controlled that you trimmed it I did for
the episodes yes so what you're gonna
find out and this has nothing to do with
my Herricks my hair was very big before
was that Parks and Rec is gonna take
place three years in the future this
season is gonna be three years in the
future but I do a different show called
house alized so I had to cut my hair but
one person yeah 20 million people watch
your television program I got to take
what I can get all right but so there's
a movie that I did Robert Zemeckis
directed this film called the walk and
in it I took I was for like a man from
the 70s so I could also place from the
70s and I grew up this huge hair and I
have muttonchops and I have a mustache
and we might have a picture of it I
believe is you on the set yes that's me
that is yeah anyway it's that and when
we're in our garb and when we're in our
outfit and stuff like that it's amazing
and it looks in character but the second
I put on normal clothes and I go out in
the world everybody stays away from me I
just the shadiest porno actor it's just
terrible so look that if you're in a 70s
context it's fine but then you're out in
the world today and you're a creep yes
and so what I did is because III I
thought weird understand why people were
weirded out by it but some of my friends
have kids and I want to know if they
need a babysitter so I made a video I
made a video if they wanted me to hang
out with their kids or whatever and I
think and that's with this look yeah
that's what this exact thing
[Music]
no babysitting job there he goes do you
like that guy what a great guy I can't
wait to run into that guy did you
livestream with The Simpsons writer I
did I think you'd simply do you guys
watch The Sims was this the sense it for
the Simpsons marathon yeah so on FXX
into this huge mace showed like every
episode yes so Matt Selman who's an
executive producer writer on The
Simpsons and Conan actually wrote for
you know the Simpsons for a time the
Simpsons are amazing and especially that
time it's just such a beauty it's like
it's one of the best written shows of
all time but uh we got eight and a half
hours of writers from The Simpsons
coming in watching the episodes and
talking about it and for me it's like a
beautiful that was fun that you got to
be a part of that it was crazy and I
hear that you're gonna do something soon
for the big live show there's a live
show at the Hollywood Bowl this weekend
yeah that I will make an appearance yeah
that's crazy that's gonna be fun lot of
great stuff I've heard it's going to be
amazed lotta great stuff planned
you